vinnie acura the sponsors of this next
segment are helping build the baby's
bounty diaper bank here's how you can
too
[Music]
my name is travis here at the valley's
best kept secret finley acura i'm here
with baby's bounty today they have a
really great cause
and uh we really wanted to partner up
with them we get the opportunity to meet
a lot of different
organizations and a lot of great people
here in the community and this is one
that we thought we really wanted to
partner up with and bring some awareness
to a recent milestone that they just had
and
everything that they're doing in the
community so now i want to introduce you
to kelly maxwell with babies bounty hi
i'm kelly maxwell the executive director
of baby's bounty a non-profit here in
southern nevada working to
solve a diaper need as well as provide
newborn supplies for our southern
nevada's tiniest residents we're so
honored to partner with finlay acura
findlay automotive group
for the benefit of southern nevada's
residence we just celebrated a really
exciting milestone 17 months ago we
created our diaper banks in response to
the overwhelming need that we saw as a
result of the pandemic
so we've distributed 1 million diapers
and 3 million wipes to 17 000 southern
nevada residents over 13 years we've
been providing newborn supplies our
initial programming was the baby bundle
program which provides basically a baby
shower and a bag all the items you need
to care for a newborn for the first six
months of life and the critical
education to keep your newborn safe and
healthy
so you can qualify for that you can go
on our website babiesbounty.org to learn
all about that program and then you can
always attend our diaper banks by
registering online at babiesbounty.org
particularly over the last 17 months the
need is incredible we we helped 63
families the first week that we launched
our diaper bank we expect to serve
between five and six hundred this week
we wouldn't be able to have the impact
that we've had in this community without
the help of
corporate sponsors like findlay acura
and the findlay automotive group
many other corporate sponsors throughout
the valley as well as really generous
individuals if folks want to help they
can always donate on our website if you
don't feel comfortable donating cash we
always need diapers
particularly the larger size fours fives
and sixes and wipes as well
thank you to finley acura for sponsoring
this segment you can visit them and drop
off supplies on auto mall drive in
henderson for more information call 702
982 4100 or head to findlay
findlayaccurate.com